in today's legal minute we're learning
about personal injury claims eric
palacios from eric palacios and
associates the sponsors of this segment
tells us more
i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal
minute this week's question is how long
do i have to settle a personal injury
claim we're going to discuss three main
points number one in nevada you have two
years from the date of the accident to
reach an agreement with the insurance
company if you don't you may lose your
right to compensation forever number two
the only way to extend this time is by
filing a lawsuit in court this lengthens
the time you have to settle your claim
and number three although you have two
years to negotiate your case you don't
want to wait to seek medical attention
as soon as you're injured as soon as you
suffer an accident it's important to go
see your doctor this has been the legal
minute we'll see you next week
for more information call the number on
your screen or visit ericblasioslaw.com
las vegas